[موسيقى]
اسعد الله مسائكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض التي نقدم من
خلالها ابرز اخبار ملفات السعوديه والخليج
وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
قمه امريكيه صينيه كسرت الجليد بين
البلدين
اوبك تخفض وتوقعاتها للطلب على النفط في
2022 وتقول بان الاقتصاد العالمي دخل
مرحله صعبه من الضبابيل
العدل السعوديه تقر قواعد جديده للحد من
تعارض مصالح المحامين من اعضاء السلك
القضائيس سابقا
ومن ملفاتنا الاخرى في الرابعه كذلك
الرابعه تستضيف شابه سعوديه تبرعت في جزء
من كبدها للطفله لا تعرفها
افتتاح حصالتين رقم ثلاثه واربعه في مطار
الرياض وتخصيص رحلات في جماهير كاس العالم
عبقر
حياكم الله اجتمع الرئيسانا الامريكي جو
بايدن والصينيه
قمه العشرين في اندونيسيا واعرض الرئيس
بايدا لنظيره شيبنج عن امله في تجنبه نزاع
بين واشنطن وبكين و بانه يسعى دائما
لابقاء قنوات الاتصال مع الصين مفتوحه لا
فتن الى ان امام البلدين فرصا كثيره كما
اوضح بيضا خلال الاجتماع ان العالم ينتظر
من واشنطن وبكين لعب دوري اساسي في مواجهه
الازمات
رئيس الامريكي
لان العالم ينتظره من واشنطن وبكين لعب
دور مهم في مواجهه التحديات العالميه
وخلال لقائه بالرئيس الامريكي جو بايتن في
بالي قال الرئيس الصيني شيجن بنج ان
العلاقات بين الصين والولايات المتحده تمر
الان بحاله لا تصب في مصلحه البلدين
والشعبين مشيرا الى ضروره ايجاد الطريق
الصحيح لهذه العلاقه
الولايات المتحده مره عبر 50 سنه حفله
بالاحداث التاريخ هو افضل كتاب لذلك علينا
ان نستفيد منه العلاقات بين الصين
والولايات المتحده حاليا تمر بحاله تدفعنا
للاهتمام بها ولا تصب في مصلحه بلدين
وشعبين وليست ما يتوقعه من المجتمع الدولي
لاننا قائدين لاكبر دولتين في العالم
علينا ان الصيغه الطريقه المناسبه
للعلاقات لايجاد الاتجاه الصحيح للعلاقه
الثنائيه مستقبلا وتطوير هذه العلاقات بين
المركز الاعلامي لقمه مجموعه العشرين في
بالي ينضم الينا موفد العربيه محمد
الطميحي مساء الخير محمد مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض نبدا باللقاء
المتوقع وهو اللقاء الذي حدث بين الرئيسين
الامريكي والصيني استرعى الكثير من
الاهتمام في وسائل الاعلام العالميه هذا
اليوم كيف تابعته وكيف رصدته وايضا حتى
الحافه من خلفك كيف رصدت هذا لقاء وعلقت
عليه
وحتى قبل انتظار نتائج النهائيه
والبيان الختامي لقمه مجموعه 23 في بالي
يبدو بان هذا الاجتماع هو الاهم حتى الان
فيما يتعلق بمستقبل سياسه العالميه نعلم
مؤخرا بان هناك جدلا كبيرا كان ما بين
بكين واشنطن هناك الكثير من الخلافات
المتعلقه بتايوان ومتعلقه بالكثير من
الملفات المتعلقه ايضا بتقارب صيني الروسي
خاصه بعد الحرب في اوكرانيا هذا التقارب
سبقه تقارب اوروبي مع الصين وربما كانت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من خلال هذا
اللقاء المرتقب الذي ربما لم يكن احد
يتوقع بان يخرج حتى الان بهذه همم
النتائجه بهذه التصريحات الايجابيه
المتعلقه بفتح باب للحوار وتجنب الخلافات
وبالمناسبه هذا الاجتماع الذي تابعنا
مقاطع منه قبل قليل عبر وسائل الاعلام
استمر لاكثر من ساعتين وختم قبل قليل فكان
اجتماعا محوريا واذا مشاهدنا اللقطات
الاولى لهذه الجلسه الحواريه وهذه القمه
ما بين شيبينج وبين الرئيس جو بايدن
سنلاحظ بانها تسير على مسارى مختلفه مسار
سياسي يتمثل في وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
ومسار اقتصاد باخر يتمثل في وزاره الخزانه
الامريكيه فبالتالي هذا التقارب سيعكس
بشكل ايجابي على قمه همم
وايضا على مستقبل العلاقات الامريكيه
وبالتالي على الاستقرار في العالم اذا
صارت النتائج حسب المؤمن والمتوقعنا احد
العناوين المهمه لهذه القمه قبل ان تبدا
طبعا هي صحه وزير الخارجيه الروسي يصير
لافروف والتي دارت حولها الكثير من الحديث
هذا اليوم همم محمد في بالي ما الجديد في
همم ما يخص البروف الاسباب انت وفرت
معلومات حولها
في الحقيقه ربما كانت هذه الاخبار التي
دارت حول صحه وزير الخارجيه الروسي
اثارت انتباهها اكثر لا يقل ربما عن
الانتباه الذي اثاره اللقاء الذي جمع
الرئيس جوبيدر اللافته في هذه القصه هو
النفي ال ال ال ال ربما النفي المضحك وهي
عادت
ما يتعلق بما فيه لعدد من هذه الاخبار
ظهر من شرفه
الغرفه او الجناح الذي ينزل هنا في في
بالي وهو يلبس ملابس همم ربما لم تكن نفس
الملابس اللي دائما اتعوضها من يتعلق
بالبدله بالرسمي
وبجامه اشبه بجامه وملابس خفيفه تتناسب مع
هذه الاجواء الرطبه اليوم في باليين في
هذه المعلومات همم يقول مثلا لا دخان من
دون نار وكاله التيرس عندما نقلت هذا
الخبر ذكرت بانها نقلت عن ثلاثه مصادر
رسميه اندونيسيه لم تسميها صراحه ولكن
النفي الروسي كان واضحا ما اذا كان
الابروف دخل الى المستشفى فقط لاجراء
روتيني للكشف عن صحته بعد ربما رحله سفر
طويله ام انهم بالفعل قد تعرض لازمه قلبيه
دخلته الى المستشفى ولكن بالتاكيد بان
الابروف سيشارك في قمه جيت 20
موسكو بعد غياب الرئيس
السعودي برئاسه ولي العهد السعوديه سيصل
ايضا الى اندونيسيا
للمشاركه في هذه القمه والحضور ايضا
السعودي في قمه العشرين ما هي تفاصيل متى
من الممكن ان يكون موعد وصول الوفد
السعودي الى هذه القمه وكذلك ابرز الملفات
التي ستناقش في اجتماع يوم الغد
حسب المصادر المحليه هنا في بالي
والمطالعه على جدول وصول للزعماء والرؤساء
طبعا من المؤكد نايف لابد المؤكد بان
المملكه خاصه بعد نجاحها في تنظيم قمه
العشرين في 20 20 خاصه في ظل الازمه
كورونا تعتبر لاعبا مهما ومحوريه في ما
يتعلق بنجاح اعمال القمه كعامل مؤثر في
اسواق الطاقه واستقرار اسواق الطاقه
المصادر المحليه كانت تتحدث عن وصول سمو
ولي العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان في ساعه مبكرا من
صباح الغد للمشاركه في اعمال هذه القمه
طبعا كان هناك مشاركات سعوديه بارزه في ما
يتعلق بالاجتماعات الثنائيه اجتماع مثلا
مجلس الماليه وزاره الماليه والصحه فيما
يتعلق
بالمساعد للخروج من الازمه الراهنه وفيما
يتعلقوصا في مجال الصحه والاستقرار على
مستوى العالم في المجال الصحيح خاصه بعد
حتى كورونا اليوم شهيدنا ايضا تفاهم سعودي
اندونيسي فيما يتعلق بانتاج همم
الهيدروجين
والامونيا وهذا جزء من تحول البلدين فيما
يتعلق بانتاج الطاقه النظيفه بالتاكيد
مشاركه المملكه ستكون فاعل على مستوى
القمه غدا خاصه فيما يتعلق بالدور المحوري
للمملكه في اسواق الطاقه العالميه شكرا
جزيلا لك على كل هذه المعلومات على كل هذه
التفاصيل التي نقلتها الينا من مقر انعقاد
قمه مجموعه العشرين في بالي تحديدا من
المركز الاعلامي المنفذ العربي محمد
الطميحي شكرا لك
قال صندوق النقد الدولي ان التوقعات
الاقتصاديه العالميه اكثر كابه من ما كانت
عليه الشهر الماضي واضاف الصندوق في تقرير
لقمه زعماء مجموعه العشرين ان الاقتصادات
الضعيفه تواجه مخاطر متزايده لازمه الديون
السياديه بينما يلحق تفاقم ازمه الطاقه في
اوروبا ضررا بالغا بالنمو ويرفع التضخم
وخفض الصندوق الشهر الماضي توقعته لنمو
العالمي لعام 2023 الى سبعه من عشره في
المئه من توقع سابق بلغ اثنين فاصله تسعه
في المئه
اعلنت منظمه اوبك عن خطي توقعاتها لنمو
طلب العلمي على النفط العام الجاري للمره
الخامسه منذ ابريل مشيره الى ان العالم
سيواجه تحديات اقتصاديه متصاعده بما في
ذلك ارتفاع التضخم وزيادات في اسعار
الفائده اوبك كشفت ايضا في تقريرها الشهري
عن توقعتها بارتفاع الطلب على نفقه في
2022 الى اكثر من اثنين مليون برميل يوميا
ما يعادل نسبه
2.6% من انخفاض 100 الف برميل عن توقعات
اوبيك الماضيه
هكذا وزير الدفاع اليمنيه في تصريحات
للعربيه ان القوات المسلحه اليمنيه بكل
تشكيلتها لديها عدو واحد يتمثل في
الميليشيات الحوثيه مؤكدا انهم بصدد
لتشكيل غرفه عمليات المشتركه لاداره
المعركه في كل الجبهات
رئاسي نقل السلطه اشتركت في كل مكونات
الشرعيه في هذا في المناطق المحره في هذا
المجلس وهذه المكونات كلها يعني
ابدت نوع من التناسق والتناغم فيما بينها
بحيث ان القوات المسلحه كلها يجب ان توجه
صوب الخطر الحقيقي الذي
مثل الحوثيين وهنا التجاوب كثير وقدمات
قياده وزاره الدفاع ورئ السيد الاركان
العامه بالتنسيق مع هذه المكونات ومجلس
القياده الرئاسي في ما بينه على شكل غرفه
عمليات المشتركه تدير هذه العمليات في كل
الجبهات وكان في الجوف في مارب في المناطق
الجنوبيه في اتجاه الساحل الغربي وهناك
همم تناغم مؤشرات اا ايجابيه جدا
كما اكد وزير الدفاع اليمني في تصريحه
للعربيه ان الحكومه لديها خطط بديله اذا
انهارت الهدره بشكل كامل مشيرا لان
المعركه ستكون غير تقليديه
القوات المسلحه هي جاهزه ومعها قوات
التحالف والقوات الدائمه كلها همم
يعني تريد من وراء هذه الهدنه هو احلال
السلام في هذا البلد تكون الحربته ارهقت
شعبه خلال الفتره الطويله هذه لكن
تريد ان تفرض اشياء اخرى وفي حاله همم
انهيارنا
واللجوء الى الحرب هناك عدد من القطط
البديله من الثقه في التحالف ومن الثقه
بين كل المكونات
سيكون حتما علينا هذه الحرب وستكون همم
همم غير تلك الحروب التقليديه السابقه
الرابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل ايضا
الرابعه تستضيف شابه سعوديه تبرعت بجزء من
كبد من كبدها لطفله لا تعرفها
حياكم الله من جديد التبرعوا بالاعضاء
ثقافه تتزايد في المجتمع السعودي مع تسهيل
الاجراءات للمتبرعين وجود مراكز الطبيه
متقدمه لزراعه الاعضاء الجوهره سعوديه
جسدت موقفا انسانيا بالتبرع لطفله لا
تعرفها التفاصيل مع زميله غدا الفهد
[موسيقى]
ما بين الالم والامل موقف انساني نبيل
جسدته الشابه السعوديه الجوهره الحجيل
عندما تبرعت بجزء من كبدها للطفله جمانه
الحربي بعد سماعها عن معاناتها من احد
صديقاتها
تالمت
كيف طفله صغيره اصلا تتالم يعني الكبير
اوكي يمشي الوقت بس صغيره
[موسيقى]
او ايا كان انه كان تسمح انه انا اتبرع كم
مره
[موسيقى]
الجوهر الشبت والعشينيه
مخاوي فقبل الاقدام على عمليه التبرع سوى
الخوف من معارضه اهلها
الداخلي وقناعتها بانسانيه ما تقوم به
اقدمت على اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
يعني قدامهم طويله ومدرسون
فسبحان الله شيء مكتوب انسان ما يدري وين
الفرج من الفرج من اهل الخير
ان الله يكتب اجرها يعني صدق صدق يعني
اعتبرها اخت جومانه ما اعتبرها والله اذا
شفتيها قبل سنه ما قلت هذه يعني قبل سنه
ما تقولي
ما شاء الله تبارك الله
قامت به الجوهره معروفا لن ينسوه وهم
يشاهدون طفلتهم الصغيره تستعد حيويتها
التي غيبها المراه
غدا الفهد العربيه الرياض
يه
للطفله اهلا وسهلا فيك الجوهره ايضا ينضم
الينا والد الطفله جمانه وجمانه كمان ايضا
الحربي اهلا وسهلا فيك منور
بعد ثمان شهور صار فيه تغير باللون العيون
فهذا يعني كان سبب عدم الفحص المستمر صباح
الامانه بعد الولاده بشهر بشهرين همم
المستشفى الحرس الوطني
هذا القصه وهي عمرها ثمانيه شهور تقريبا
الكلام هذا من سنتين طيب وبحث نعم وتعرف
الامور هذه شوي صعبه
همم امورها زينه يعني ليش تاخذ خطوره
الهاتف
انها تتبرع لطفله او لاحد اصلا ما تعرفه
ثقافه التبرع عندنا شويه معدومه بالنسبه
لي انا يعني الامانه حرام او من الانانيه
بدنا نحتفظ باعضاء من جسمنا نفسنا بس يعني
زي الكبد زي الكلى ما راح يضرنا اذا
يتبرعنا فيه الكبد يتدخل
الكلى تقدر تعيش فيها بوحده في اجزاء
كثيره
في ناس كثير او متضررين كثير او مرضى كثير
يعني يتوفون من التعب هذا
انا اشوف الانانيه ان احنا نحتفظ بهذا
الشيء نفسنا
الموضوع هذا الثقافه الشخص اللي يجب انه
يتبرع الذي ثقافه موجوده عندك من زمان
وكنت تفكري فيها قبل انه تصير همم
جمانه بس انه جاء الوقت المناسب معها اللي
انت ما كنتي تعرفيها اصلا
فعلا انا تقريبا من عمري 15 سنه وانا
جالسه اطلع كثير من ضمن الاطلاع اللي انا
جلسه اقراه والقراءات اللي انا جئت اقراها
كرهت عن الكبد انه في عمر 15 سنه
ينمو الانسان ما راح اصلا يتضرر منه من
فقدانها جزء منها
ثلاثه في موضوع التمر في اجراءات
يعني
معروف يعني ما احد يقدر يسهل الامان
موقف كانت يعني بين الحيوانات
[موسيقى]
لا الصحه حتى برودك تعطي حد صحتك
اليوم
مقابله اليوم
طيب همم
انا اللي اعرفه الجوهره انه انت سويتها
العمليه من دون اهلك ما يعرفوا لانهم كان
معارضين هل العمليه وكليه للقصه وشلون مو
انت طبعا ما تقدرتي تقنعيهم لكن شلون
بلغيهم
م
اعطيتهم نبذه عن التبر ان الانسان يقدر
يتبرع
ما شفت اي قبول لما انا قلت انه انا ارغب
اني اتبرع مني انا عندي هذا الفكره
الامانه ما لقيت اي قبول في هذا الموضوع
فين يعني انه انا اقدر اقوم بخير انه في
يعني في يقين داخلين وانا بكون شخص يعني
بصحه وعافيته كامله
بسال عن عن اسرتك وعن افراد العائله عندك
يوم من الايام قال لك سنتين معك سنتين
الشهاده
اخذت وقت لما انت قلتي لهم انا حتبرع لاحد
مستشفى الحرس الوطني
كيف عرفت كنت ابحث كثير بس ما بحثت لان
كان في امور عندي بخلصها بحث في تقريبا
السنه هذه لانه انا احتاج اني انا اتبرع
بجزء منك
فدلوني على ابو جمانه
هي عائله ما قالوا انها هي بنت صغيره
تحتاج الكبد انه واحده من افرادها في فشل
الكبد لانه حالتها مره خلاص ابدا
انا اصلا داخل المستشفى بتبروا عندها
الموضوع يعني ما همني
وخليني اسال عن ردود فعل الناس الي حولك
لما اعرف انه انت رحتي تبرعتي وما كان
الاهل ما كانوا يعرفوا وانت كنت بهذا
العمل مثل ما قلتوا انه في يقين وفي دافع
وفي ثقافه تبرع حسيت انه غيرتي شيء من
الناس اللي حوالك
مختلفه تماما حول ثقافه التبرع انا شفت في
نظرتهم فخر الامانه قبل ما كانت موجوده في
هذا الشيء همم
غيرت او في ناس يسالوني كثير عن التبرع
كيف نقدم عليه انا شفت انه يعني
الحرس الوطني
انا بالحد الجنوبي
متواصلين معي المواعيدها اللي بتحتاج دي
تحاليلها اي شيء يصير لها لا تشيل هم يجون
هالبيت يقولون هالمستشفى كل الامور ميسره
الله يقويك ان شاء الله يحفظ عليك الصحه
والعافيه
الجوهره اشكرك جزيل الشكر لحضورك معنا
وشكرا ابو جمانه يكفي يعتقد ما عاد اقدر
ازيده شكرا جزيلا شكرا
الرابعه وبالصحه ان شاء الله والعافيه
دائما همم عليكم
[موسيقى]
الطفله وولد الطفله نافع الحربي والطفل
ايضا جمانه شكرا لكم جميعا
هذه صور مباشره نقلها لكم من جزيره بالي
الاندونيسيه الجزيره التي
ستستضيف اعمال قمه مجموعه ال جي 20
كما نشاهد الان هذه الصور للمؤتمر الصحفي
المرتقب لرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن والتي
يعني كانت وسائل الاعلام قد سلطت الضوء
عليها طبعا وعلى يعني هذه القمه صلاه
الظهر كذلك ايضا على قمه الرئيس الامريكي
والرئيس الصيني همم
طبعا البيت الابيض قال بان بيضا والرئيس
الصيني بحث الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا
البيت الابيض اضاف كذلك بان بيض ابلغ
نظيره الصيني ان المنافسه بين البلدين لا
يجب ان تؤدي ل همم
نحن الان
همم نتابع واياكم هذه الصوره
المباشره
لمقر همم المقر الذي سيعقد في المؤتمر
الصحفي لرئيس الامريكي جوبيدن طبعا البيت
الابيض اضافه بان بيض وشى تحدث بصراحه حول
القضايا الخلافيه بين البلدين وربما كان
هو العنوان الاهم والابرز هذا اليوم في
هذه القمه وهذا الاجتماع
الاندونيسيه قبل يومين من انطلاق مجموعه
الجيت وانت التي تضم اكبر 20 اقتصاد في
العالم
وبانتظار طبعا ظهور الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن في هذا المؤتمر الصحفي هذا المؤتمر
هذا اللقاء ايضا مع الرئيس الصيني شيجن
بنج ياتي بعد ايام من الانتخابات انتخابات
التجديد النصفي في الكونغرس الامريكي نعلم
ايضا بان الحزب الديمقراطي احتفظ باغلفيته
في مجلس الشيوخ وبانتظار طبعا النتيجه
النهائيه لمجلس همم النواب وحسن مقاعد
[موسيقى]
وزاره العدل السعوديه قواعد الحد من تعرض
المصالح لمن سبق له العمل في السلك
القضائي ومن في حكمه عند مزاوله مهنه
المحاماه وتهدف هذه القواعد للحفاظ على
نزاهه المرفق العدلي حيث تطبق احكامها
بالتنسيق مع هيئه الرقابه ومكافحه الفساد
والهيئه السعوديه للمحامين اوضحت وزاره
العدل ان تلك القواعد تؤكد على مسؤوليه
الممارسين بالتاكد من عدم وجود حالات
تعارضا للمصالح او مخالفه للاحكام قبل
الموافقه على القيام باي عمل من اعمال
المحنه
ينضم الينا من الرياضه المحاميه
والمستشاره القانوني مصطفى ظافر سيد مصطفى
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
في فبراير الماضي نشرت وزاره العدل على
صفحتها في تويتر استطلاعا للراي حول احكام
وقواعد هذا التنظيم فيما يخص المحامين
الذين كانوا قد عملوا في وقت سابق في
السلك القضائي اول ما هي ابرز احكام
وقواعد هذه التنظيمات الجديده يعني طلعت
عليها
حياكم الله اهلا وسهلا بالنسبه للقواعد
اللي نشرتها وزاره العدل ونشرت ايضا في
منصه استطلاع الاستطلاع راي العموم تشريع
للحد من تعارض والمصالح او حالات تعرض
المصالح المحتمله همم من الممارسين في
القطاع في قطاع مهنه المحاماه من من سبق
لهم العمل في همم السلك القضائي طبعا هي
حددت هذه القواعد اول شيء منهم المقصودين
او المخاطبين بها وهم العاملين في السلك
القضائي سواء كانوا من اعضاء النيابه
العامه او العاملين كخبار في محاكم همم
تابع لوزاره العدل همم ايضا تتضمن القواعد
عدد من المده الزمنيه همم اللي تمنع من
كان يعمل في اخر سنه او القضايا اللي طلع
عليها بحكم عمله في السلك القضائي في اخر
سنه ثم انتقل الى قطاع المحاماه همم تمنع
تضع مده زمنيه مده سنتين همم
ممارسه اي عمل من من الاعمال للقلعه عليها
اثناء عمله في السلك القضائي همم ايضا
القواعد تطرقت الى جوانب تخص
الاثار المترتبه على حالات عرض مصالح سواء
يعني اليوم كان في
الاقرار اقرار القواعد من المعالي وزير
العدل والخبر اللي نشر في حساب همم
الوزاره همم يعني تطرق الى طريقه تفعيل
هذا القواعد طيب خلينا نسال عن اليوم اتت
هذه القواعد لربما تعالج همم لا نسميه همم
فراغ ولكن ربما تعالج مصالح قد تتضارب
فانا اسال عن السابق كيف كانت تتعارض همم
المصالح لمن كان يعمل في السلك القضائي
واصبح همم محاميا وحتى لو بشكل غير مقصود
ما في شك انه حالات تعرض المصالح بالنسبه
للممارسه المهنيه والممارسه القانوني او
المحامي حاصله قد تحصل اليوم في مكتب
المحاماه حاله تعرض مصالح فيعتذر المحامي
ان ان توليها قد ينتقل المحامي من عمل اذا
كان من فريق عمل في شركه مهنيه ثم ينضم
الى شركه مهنيه اخرى فيعتذر عن بعض
القضايا بحكم وجود تعرضه مصالح كذلك كان
السابق في مساله همم يعني العمل في السلك
القضائي يعني ممكن تكون عضو نيابه او قاضي
القضايا ثم تفتح مكتب وتمارس مهنه
المحاماه تطلع على بعض التفاصيل التي طلعت
عليها بيكون عملك فكان لابد انك لابد كان
دور الوزاره تضع هذه القواعد للحد من همم
هذه الممارسات لانها وارده
سواء بحسنيه بحكم يعني الممارسات
القانونيه وبحكم ما يطلع عليه العاملين
بالسلك القضائي وما يطلع عليه العاملين
همم من مزاوله مهنه هنا والمستشاريه مصطفى
ظافر المحامي والمستشار القانوني من
العاصمه السعوديه رياض شكرا جزيلا لك
شركه مدينه جده توقعات اتفاقيه لتنفيذ
اكثر من سته الاف وحده سكنيه بقيمه
اجماليه تجاوزت مليار ريال سعودي حيث تم
تخصيصو 50% من المشاريع التي سيتم تنفيذها
لسكان الاحياء المطوره الذين ازلت منازلهم
في المحافظه وتهدف الاتفاقيه لتمكين الاسر
السعوديه في مختلف المناطق من تملك السكن
الملائم بدا من الاسر الاشد حاجه في عده
مواقع
بمحافظهين جده والطائف
برعايه سمونا ضمير منطقه مكه المكرمه
اليوم توقيع اتفاقيات لبناء اكثر من 6000
وحده سكنيه في منطقه مكه المكرمه ما بين
محافظه جده ومحافظه الطائف سيكون ان شاء
الله
قرابه 50% من هذه الوحدات ومخصصه لاهالينا
من
العشوائيات همم يكون هناك تركيز كبير ان
شاء الله في المرحله القادمه
لانهاء هذه الوحدات وتسكينهم ان شاء الله
تعالى ومستمرين في وزاره الشؤون البلديه
والقرويه والاسكان لتوفير الوحدات السكنيه
الولائمه الاهالينا في جميع مناطق المملكه
كشف وزير السياحه السعوديه احمد الخطيب عن
اطلق منصه سياحيه خليجيه موحده وذلك على
هامشي اجتماعي وزراء السياحه الخارجيه في
العلا
وعملنا اجتماع سياحي بكل المقاييس ناقشنا
بنود الاجتماع لعشره بنود اتفقنا عليها
بالكامل كان من اهمها اطلاق المنصه
السياحيه الموحده واللي
تركز او تعطي معلومات عن المواقع السياحيه
وتقدم سياحيه وتقدم الفعاليات السياحيه
اللي موجوده في دول الخليج من نافذه واحده
منطقه الخليج منطقه اثريه لم تاخذ حصتها
من سوق السياحه العالمي الى الان حصتنا
تقريبا 5% من سوق السياحه على العالمي
امامنا مشوار طويل الى الوصول الى
طموحاتنا وطموحات الشعوب
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض بدا اليوم تشغيل
الصلاتين الدوريتين رقم ثلاثه واربعه في
مطار الملك خالد الدولي وذلك بعد اكتمال
لاعمال التطوير فيها
[موسيقى]
واضح وزير النقل والخدمات اللوجستيه في
السعوديه المهندس صالح الجاسر ان بدات
تشغيل الصلاتين ثلاثه واربعه بمطار الملك
خالد سيسهم في دعم حركه السفر الدولي
بالتزامن مع انطلاق بطوله كاس العالم لكره
القدم
2022 اضافه لنمو حركه السفر وتمكين انقطاع
السياحي والاقتصادي تم تجهيز الصلاه بعدد
من المكونات المهمه سواء التجهيزات
الامنيه او التجهيزات الخدميه عدد
الكاونترات 95
كاونتر كاونترات الجوازات
مناطق التفتيش مناطق الراحه صلاه الانتظار
البوابات
ذات الجسور والبوابات
للحافلات ويعني كل التجهيزات تكاملت في
هذا اليوم لاطلاق اول رحله باذن الله
متجهه الى قطر لموسانده المنتخب الوطني
وان شاء الله يكونوا يعني
المشجعين لكاس العالم اول المستفيدين من
هذه الصالات
مطارات القابضه سليمان البسام ان تشغيلها
للصلاتين ثلاثه واربعه يبدا بالرحلات
التردديه والمجدوله بطاقه استيعابيه تصل ل
700 الف مقعد كما توفيرها لجميع الناقلات
الجوي
توزيع التشغيل طبعا يمر مراحل كثيره طبعا
الحركه الجويه الان الصاله ثلاثه واربعه
اللي احنا فيها الان هنبدا فيها همم رحلات
كاس العالم للدوحه للرحلات التردديه
والرحلات المجدوله ستبدا من هذا الصالات
استعدادات مطارات المملكه استعداد كبير
جدا على كافه الاصعده وهي مكمل
الاستعدادات منظومه النقل احنا مستعدين
غرف عمليات 2300 رحله تقريبا في جميع
مطارات المملكه طاقه استيعابيه الى
700,000 مقعد وفرناها لجميع الناقلات
الجويه وغرف عمليات على مدار الساعه همم
بمواقف للمسافرين في جميع المطارات فرق
عمل تعمل على مدار الساعه بالتعاون مع
جميع الجهات الداعمه لنا في هذا المشروع
المطار الملك خالد الدولي بالرياض ينضم
الى مراسل العربيه سلطنه السلميه السلطانه
يعطيك العافيه من الظهر اليوم وانت تتواجد
بصالتين همم جديدتين صاله ثلاثه او اربع
او التي اعد فتحهما في مطار الملك خالد
الدولي في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض ابرز
الارقام المعلومات همم الطاقه الاستيعابيه
كذلك لهتين الصلاتين حتى الان
اهلا بك نايف اهلا بكافه المشاهدين قناه
العربيه من مطار الملك خالد الدولي هنا
بالرياض وتحديدا من صاله رقم التي شهدت
اليوم تدشين هذه الصاله بجانب صاله رقم
اربع نتحدث على مساحه اجماليه لتلك
الصالحتين تصل الى 100 و 124.000 متر مربع
لتحدث عن استعدادات كبيره لتشغيل وتفسير
الرحلات من هذه الصلاتين والتحديدا من
والى الرياض وكذلك الى همم قطر من خلال
همم المسافرين الراغبين بالتوجه من
السعوديه او حتى مرورا بالسعوديه او من
الرياض تهديدا الى قطر لمتابعه كاس العالم
اريد ان اخذكم في جوله داخل هذه الصاله
وتحديدا صاله رقم اربعه هذه الصاله التي
تتمتع بكافه الخدمات اللوجستيه المتعلقه
بخدمات السفر من الاسواق حره وكذلك نتحدث
عن المطاعم والمقاهي المتعلقه بخدمه
المسافرين بشكل مباشر ايضا نتحدث على
الطاقه استيعابيه لتلك الصلاتين تصل الى
13 مليون مسافر سنويا نتحدث كذلك على
توفير كافه الكوادر البشريه والفنيه
لتشغيل هذا المطانه تحدث على 95 كاونتر
تسجيل ثمانيه سيور عملاق وضخمه لنقل
الامتعه كذلك 22 بوابه سفر رئيسيه نتحدث
على 38 كاونتر خاص للجوازات المغادره
وثمانيه واربعين كاونتر للجوازات للقدوه
هنالك 12 جهاز خدمه ذاتيه يستطيع من
خلالها المسافر انهاء اجراءات السفر عبر
هذه الاجهزه كذلك في ما يتعلق بالقطاعه لا
من هنالك 14 جهاز تفتيش امني وثلاث صالات
لخدمه رجال الاعمال من خلال التذاكر
لدرجات الاعمال وغيرها من من الباقات
والخدمات المقدمه ايضا استكمال اعمال
التطوير في هذه الصاله يعني هو حدث مهم
بطبيعه الحال من خلال خدمه ال- خدمه
الركاب المسافرين في مدينه الرياض وحتى
المجاوره في
منطقه الرياض اليوم هذه الخطوه هي خطوه
مهمه لتكريس مدينه الرياض كمحور ربط عالمي
يسهم او يسهم في نمو حركه السفر وتمكين
القطاع السياحه والاقتصادي في السعوديه
ايضا تحدث على وجود اليوم كافه الطيران
الدولي يستطيع اليوم السفر من هذه
الصالتين صار رقم ثلاثه وصار رقم اربعه
ايضا سوف تستمر بالعمل صار رقم واحد وصار
رقم اثنين وسوف تبقى صله رقم خمسه لتقديم
خدمات السفر للطيران المحلي ايضا كمرحله
اولى سوف تكون هذه الصلاتين سوف تخدم بشكل
مباشر كافه الرحلات المسيره او التي سوف
تجيء الى قطر لحضور لكاس العالم وايضا
وبعدين انتهاء كاس العالم سوف تركز بشكل
كبير لتفسير كافه الرحلات الى الوجهات
الدوليه فيما يتعلق بصاله واحد واثنين سوف
بحسب المصادر سوف تلقى اعمال ترميم وعدد
تاريخ الفتره القادمه واعمال طويل واا
الترميم في المطار مستمره بشكل كبير لوصول
اكبر لانه يعني ليصال او عمل التحسينات
اللازمه لاصال الخدمه المناسبه لكافه
المسافرين عبر مطر او عبر مطار الرياض
بشكل كبير اليوم حضور ضخم وكبير من كافه
مسؤولين يعني
اغلاقه ولو مؤقتا حسب
ما عرفت
نعم في ظل تشغيل هذه الصالتين رقم ثلاثه
واربعه من المتوقع بحسب المصادر انه صاله
رقم واحد وصال رقم اثنين سوف تشهد يعني
اغلاق جزئي لاعمال التحسين وكذلك رفع
مستوى الخدمه بها وسوف تفتح بعد الانتهاء
منها بشكل مباشر وذلك سوف تعمل خمس صالات
في المستقبل القريب بشكل كامل ممتاز اشكرك
على كل هذه المعلومات التفاصيل مطار الملك
خالد الدولي بالرياض مراسل العربيه سلطان
استلمه شكرا لك سلطان
اعلنت المؤسسه العامه للحبوب في السعوديه
اكثر من مليون طن من القمح لتوريدها من
دول عده ابرزها الاتحاد الاوروبي وامريكا
الشماليه والجنوبيه عبر 6 10 باخره في
اربع موانئ حول المملكه المؤسسات السعوديه
اوضحت ان موسمه شراء القمح المحلي انتهى
لهذا العام وذلك بشراء اكثر من 500,000 طن
من القمح
الرابعه مستمره
وفيها بعد قليل
وزاره الماليه السعوديه تطرق نظاما جديدا
لدفع الالكتروني لرسوم الخدمات الحكوميه
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديد اعلن الديوان الملكي
السعودي عن مغادره ولي العهد رئيس مجلس
الوزراء الامير محمد بن سلمان اليوم
الاثنين
مملكه المشاركه في قمه قاده دول مجموعه
العشرين التي ستعقد في مدينه بالي
بجمهوريه اندونيسيا كما سيقوم الامير محمد
بن سلمان لزياره عدد من الدول الاسيويه
ومن منطلق التواصل وتعزيز العلاقات بين
المملكه والدول الصديقه واستجابه للدعوات
المقدمه حيث يلتقي خلالها قادتها وعددا من
المسؤولين فيها لبحث العلاقات الثنائيه
ومناقشه القضايا ذات الاهتمام المشترك
اعلنها صندوق الاستثمارات العامه في
السعوديه توقيع مذكرتي تفاهم مع شركه بلوك
لاستكشافي فرص الاستثمار في البنيه
التحتيه في السعوديه والشرق الاوسط وشمالي
افريقيا وتشمل القطاعات المستهدفه الطاقه
والكهرباء والمرافق والمياه والبيئه
والنقل والاتصالات والبنيه التحتيه
الاجتماعيه حيث يسعد طرفان الى جذب
مستثمرين اقليمينا ودوليين
الاجنبيه تسهم في تحقيق عوائد مستدامه على
المدى الطويل
اطلقت وزاره الماليه السعوديه خدمه الدفع
الالكترونيه لرسوم الخدمات الحكوميه من
خلال نظام تحصيل للجهه الحكوميه والتي
تهدف لتطوير وتنظيم البنيه التحتيه في
التقنيات الماليه للجهات الحكوميه
والتسهيل على المستفيدين من خلال تقديم
خدمات الرقميه موحده ومتكامله وذلك ضمن
مساء الوزاره لتحقيق رؤيه السعوديه 2030
وقفه الرياضيه مع زميله للانتوري
[موسيقى]
شكرا لك نايف اهلا بكم مشاهدينا اعلن
الاتحاد الفرنسي لكره القدم ضمان
ماركوستورام مهاجم
موناكو لقائمه المنتخب التي ستخوض نهائيات
كاس العالم وقالوا الاتحاد الفرنسي
باريس سان جيرمان
الخروج من المنتخب بسبب الاصابه
اعلنها جلال القاضي المدير الفني لمنتخب
تونس قائمه اللاعبين الذين سيخذون منافسات
بطوله كاس العالم قائمه المنتخب التونسي
شهده دماما سيف الدين الجزيري مهاجم فريق
الزمالك وعلي معلول لظهير الايسر للاهلي
وضمه القائمه اسمها بلال العيفه مدافع
نادي الكويت رغم تكهنات باستبعاده وعلى
نحو غير معتاد اختار القادري اربعه حراس
للمرمى بدلا من الثلاثه وحفظ القادر على
العناصر الاساسيه بوجود علي معلول ونعيم
سليتي وهبي الخارجي ويوسف لمساكني
وها كانت بعتت المنتخب المغربي قد وصلت
ايضا الى الدوحه وضمت سبعه لاعبين بانتظار
اكتمال القائمه بوصول البقيه بعد توقف
البطولات المحليه في اوروبا
سيفقد لمنتخب خدمات امين حارس لاعب وسط
نادي مارسيليا بعد تعرضه للاصابه امام
موناكو في الدوري الفرنسي يلعب المنتخب
المغربي في المجموعه السادسه الى جانب
كرواتيا وبلجيكا وكندا
المنتخب السعودي في الرياض المرحله
الاخيره من البرنامج الاعدادي لكاس العالم
شهاده التدريبات الجماعيه مشاركه سلمان
الفرج بعد تعافه من الاصابه ويوصل المنتخب
السعودي اليوم استعداداته بحصه تدريبيه
استعدادا يوديها كرواتيا الاربعاء المقبل
اختار الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم الرياض
ودبي من بين سبع مدن الاحتضان مهرجان فيفا
للجماهير تمتد صحه المهرجان من الدوحه الى
ساو باولو في البرازيل
[موسيقى]
كل واحد ضد انه يروح يتفرج كاس العالم في
المدرجات ولكن يعني انا لو مثلا قعدت
اتابع المباريات كلها همم وكل يوم مقهى
شكل وعندنا الشاشات مثلا متوفره همم همم
نقدر نشوف مثلا بشكل واضح جامعه الشباب
عندك موجوده الكلام هذا كله حتى ما بيعادل
قيمه ممكن التذكره اصلا لحاله للخطر او
انك تروح المدرج يعني
[موسيقى]
كاس العالم في الرياض في اماكن جديده زي
كده اماكن متوفر فيها كل شيء كل فعاليه
[موسيقى]
اجواء الرياض وفعاليات الرياض وكل شيء في
الرياض الواحد يضرب العصفورين بحجر
في ناس منهم انا افضل الزحمه الزايده يعني
التنفض من الملعب ممكن اوك اجواء المباراه
بعد المباراه قبل المباراه بتعرض لزحمه
وغير كده تكاليف يعني عندك تكاليف الحضور
على مباراه وحده التكاليف هذه اذا دفعتها
اليوم في مطعم ولا كوفي لا تاخذني يعني
بتوفر لك مو مو 1,000 و2000 يعني وبنعرف
احنا التكاليف السفر الملعب
[موسيقى]
اتوقع ان شاء الله يكون في اقبال من
الزبائن ان شاء الله الفتره الجايه وان
شاء الله زياده مبيعات وكل خير ان شاء
الله
توفر الشاشات العرض انها بديل لحضور كاس
العالم في قطر
[موسيقى]
وصل المنتخب السنغال الى الدوحه الاستكمال
لاستعداداته الاخيره للمشاركه في مونديال
وقد تغيب عن الوفد مهاجم بايرن ميونخ
ساديو ماني متصدر هدافي المنتخب الاصابه
قد تمنعماني من المشاركه لكن المدرب سيسي
قرر ابقائه املا لتحسن حالته لاحقا
نهايه اخبار الرياضه شكرا لمتابعتكم اعود
الى نايف فضل نايف
[موسيقى]
شكرا ليليان في السعوديه
يقام اليوم زاد فني خيري يتضمنوا عرض
اعمال فنيه لفنانين السعوديين بالتعاون مع
اربع جمعيات خيريه وستخص جميع العوائد
الماليه من المزاد لدعم البرامج الفنيه
للجمعيات وسيتم عرض الاعمال الفنيه في حي
جاكس بالدرعيه على ان تطرح على البيع عبر
منصه اتروم
ابطال الشتويه هي الوسميه واهم الامطار
الصيفيه هيرفيه التفاصيل في تقويم مع خالد
الزعيم
[موسيقى]
تنقسم السحب الى قسمين سحب صيفيه وسحب
شتويه الشتويه امطارها هتانه اي خفيفه
فحبه المطر صغيره وسبح بها منفرشه
ومستورده ولا تعترف بعامل الوقت اي انها
تنطر يا صباح او مساء كل واحد والسحب
الصيفيه تسبق بعصفه ريح وامطارتها تكون في
بقعه دون ثانيه وحبه المطر كبيره لها صوت
دبدبه ولا تمطر الا مساءا اي من الظهر
وطالع وعاده ما تكون غزيره وتنتهي بسرعه
وفي احايل تكون مصحوبه بحبات برد الود بين
الناس ما هو مطر صيف تضحك سماء وتختفي في
ثواني الولد
وتشريف فيه احترام واصل طيبه
ومعاني
[تصفيق]
اما الامطار الشتويه الوسميه والصيفيه
الهريسيه وهي التي تاتي في اخر موسم الصيف
فهي تشبع الاجواء بالرطوبه وتهيا السحب
الوسميه للانطار والعامه يسمون السحاب
الشتوي الماطر بس سحاب المنحدر ليش لانه
ينحدر من طبقات الجو العليا الغير ماطره
الى طبقات الجو السفلى الماطره جيت مثل
السحاب ورحت مثل السراب لاني اول خطاك ولا
انت اخر همومي بيض الله وجه صبر كمجباب
لين خلى الظنون تنومه والشك
يومي
[موسيقى]
قبل ختام الرابعه هذا التذكره
الامريكيه التونسينيه كسرت الجليده بين
البلدين
2022 وتقول بان الاقتصاد العالمي دخل
مرحله صعبه من الضبابيه
تبرعت بجزء من كبدها لطفله لا تعرفها
افتتاح الصالتين رقم 43 في مطار الرياض
وتخصيص رحلات جماهير كاس العالم عبرها
شكرا لكم لكرمي ولطفي المتابعه زمير خالد
مدخل يلقاكم غدا في الرابعه
[موسيقى]